Olá você sente dores nas articulações
Tem dificuldades para dormir devido a
ansiedade ou mesmo acorda no meio da
noite sem conseguir voltar a dormir ou
talvez você esteja cansado ou cansada de
ter gripes frequentes e problemas
intestinais
recorrentes nesse vídeo eu vou falar
sobre aminoácido glicina onde
encontrá-lo nos alimentos suplementos e
o mais interessante eu vou compartilhar
com vocês três combinações
surpreendentes da glicina com outros
nutrientes que podem melhorar de forma
significativa sua saúde uma delas talvez
você já conheça que é a glicina com
magnésio ou famoso magnésio glicina ou
bisglicinato é um assunto que vale muito
a pena você acompanhar assistir até o
final para entender então vamos
lá quando falamos em colágeno pensamos
na pele já que ele fornece estrutura
elasticidade e firmeza pra nossa pele
mas o colágeno também é fundamental pros
ossos pros músculos e ligamentos
especialmente para as cartilagens e
articulações justamente para amortecer
impactos E permitir Movimento Sem Dor de
uma maneira suave o colágeno é
importante então para os discos
vertebrais da nossa coluna que hoje em
dia muita gente tem problemas por conta
de dor por falta de colágeno já que ele
dá flexibilidade e amortecimento à nossa
coluna inclusive e pensamos até nos
vasos sanguíneos onde o colágeno ajuda a
dar elasticidade às Paredes dos nossos
vasos e artérias então o colágeno é
muito importante pro nosso organismo
como um todo e quando falamos em
colágeno geralmente pensamos em vitamina
C e outros nutrientes mas muitas vezes
esquecemos dos aminoácidos da produção
de colágenos os amóes que estão
envolvidos nessa produção de colágeno
especialmente a glicina olha só que
interessante pessoal se pegarmos o nosso
colágeno Geral do organismo
aproximadamente 33% dele é feito somente
do aminoácido glicina Então pense na
importância da glicina para tudo isso
que eu acabei de mencionar mas não é só
pro colágeno a glicina é importante para
outras questões do nosso organismo como
o sistema imune a desintoxicação o
sistema nervoso e a saúde
digestório Então vamos lá vamos entender
melhor o que é glicina ela é um
aminoácido não essencial O que significa
que o nosso corpo pode produzir por
conta própria mas também podemos obter
através da alimentação e da
suplementação para que o nosso corpo
Produza glicina ele precise de outros
aminoácidos como ingredientes para
sintetizar então para vocês terem uma
ideia vamos fazer uma análise bem rápida
pegando uma pessoa média uma pessoa que
não tem problemas com relação à produção
de glicina essa pessoa vai produzir em
média 3 G de glicina ao dia e se ela
tiver uma dieta padrão boa uma dieta
contendo proteínas em abundância essa
pessoa vai consumir cerca de 3 G de
glicina também por dia então numa média
bem geral ela vai ter por volta aí de 6
g de glicina ao dia três da dieta três
da produção do próprio organismo Através
de outros aminoácidos Isso parece bom
não parece adequado
sim o problema é que muitas pessoas não
conseguem produzir glicina internamente
de forma adequada ou produzem menos
glicina já que essa produção Depende de
outros aminoácidos e há pessoas que não
consomem alimentos ciclos em glicina
portanto esses fatores podem levar a
vários problemas relacionados à falta
desse aminoácido na nossa alimentação
conseguimos glicina principalmente das
fontes de proteínas animais
especialmente da aquelas partes dos
animais que muita gente não gosta de
comer que tem nojinho e geralmente
descarta há pessoas que não gostam de
proteína animal e há pessoas que não
consomem por filosofia de vida tudo bem
nesse caso pessoas veganas ou
vegetarianas preciso se orientar com o
seu nutricionista sobre outras fontes de
glicina já que ela também pode ser
encontrada em algumas Fontes vegetais
como é o caso de feijões espinafre e
frutas mas são fontes com baixas
quantidades de glicina Então você tem
que comer muito mais para conseguir ter
a mesma quantidade falando então dos
alimentos de origem animal a glicina é
riquíssima nas partes próximas aos ossos
nas partes do animal que muita gente não
gosta como tendão e Miúdos Essas são as
mais ricas fontes de glicina o frango a
carne de boi a carne de porco Todas têm
glicina Mas você vai encontrar uma
quantidade maior nos pés de galinha por
exemplo e no caldo de ossos que é feito
com os ossos de boi e de outros animais
mas hoje em dia temos a suplementação eu
vou falar dela um pouquinho mais
adiante Então quais são as outras
funções e importâncias da glicina no
nosso organismo além de ser fundamental
para a síntese de colágeno e de
proteínas ela também ajuda
principalmente na melhoria do sono na
redução da ANS ade ela atua também na
saúde digestória auxiliando na produção
de ácidos gástricos podendo ser uma
aliada importante na digestão de
Alimentos na questão da Saúde intestinal
a glicina também tem uma função de
acalmar a inflamação pessoas que
consomem Mais Alimentos cicos em glicina
ou tomam ainda suplementos de glicina
relatam que quando o intestino está
excessivamente permeável ou a barreira
dele está danificada seus sintomas
melhoram com o uso de glicina isso é
especialmente notável em pessoas que t o
cibo né O Chamado super crescimento de
bactérias do intestino delgado ou ainda
assim no intestino irritável que se
acompanha com o cibo essas pessoas relat
uma melhora dos sintomas com a
utilização de suplementos ou alimentos
contendo glicina especialmente os
alimentos ricos em glicina ou a
suplementação então a glicina também
participa da
desintoxicação tóxico do fígado e também
tem uma importância da função
imunológica porque contribui para a
produção da glutationa que é um potente
antioxidante que protege as células
contra danos oxidativos então a glicina
faz parte da glutationa existe estudos
bem interessantes sobre a saúde do
coração mostrando que a glicina tem um
efeito protetor contra doenças
cardiovasculares Possivelmente devido à
sua ação a sua propriedade
antiinflamatória antioxidante há estudos
também em relação ao função cognitiva e
memória mostrando melhorias em condições
neurológicas especialmente em casos de
demências além disso há pesquisas que
indicam que a glicina pode melhorar a
sensibilidade insulina em pessoas com
obesidade resistência insulínica pré
diabetes ajudando a regular os níveis de
açúcar no sangue outra coisa importante
é que a glicina é um bloco de construção
da creatina a famosa creatina e com isso
ela também ajuda no crescimento e
recuperação muscular Mas falando da
combinação da glicina com outros
suplementos eu vou compartilhar três
combinações que são bem interessantes e
que podem sim ajudar em várias condições
de saúde a primeira combinação é glicina
mais vitamina C bom você deve imaginar
que estou falando sobre a melhoria da
pele como evitar rugas certo Claro Esse
é um dos benefícios mais no que diz
respeito a essa combinação o que mais me
surpreende é a questão da proteção
contra vírus sim pessoal o que acontece
é o seguinte já que a glicina é
abundante no colágeno e a vitamina C é
importante pra síntese de colágeno essa
combinação tem duplação e que o colágeno
tem a ver então com combater
vírus lembre-se de que o vírus utiliza
várias etapas para causar infecção
primeiro ele precisa infectar as células
e se multiplicar agora precisamos
entender que nossas células
especialmente a matriz
extracelular são compostas por uma
complexa rede de moléculas E adivinha o
colágeno é um dos principais componentes
dessa Matriz est celular o mais
importante e abundante nesse material
Talvez isso Explique porque a vitamina C
pode trazer proteção contra infecções
virais quando você toma frequentemente
vitamina C ela ela pode ajudar a evitar
infecções e reduzir a duração da gripe
por exemplo e uma das teorias é
justamente que ela fortalece essa Matriz
extracelular nas nossas células já quer
dizer que essa Matriz que fica entre as
nossas células já que elas são feitas em
grande parte de colágeno ajudando no
bloqueio de infecções agora além da
vitamina C lembre-se de que falei que a
glicina é fundamental paraa formação do
colágeno então a combinação de vitamina
C com glicina pode ser muito mais
efetiva na proteção contra vírus Essa
dupla dificulta a entrada do vírus nas
células e consequentemente a sua
replicação e isso é bem interessante Não
é pessoal a próxima combinação
interessante da glicina é com nac a ntil
cisteína assim como a glicina O que é
outro precursor da glutationa então a
glutationa é um poante antioxidante que
protege as células contra danos
oxidativos então pesquisas TM mostrado
que a suplementação dessa dupla glicina
mais nac melhora a deficiência de
glutationa no organismo combate os danos
mitocondriais o estess oxidativo e a
inflamação crônica estudos osos ainda
mostraram melhoras em vários fatores
característicos do envelhecimento
incluindo questões de saúde mental e
cognitiva Então essa combinação pode ser
um meio de evitar a progressão do
envelhecimento precoce e também ajudar a
controlar a inflamação crônica no nosso
organismo mesmo Eu particularmente tomo
essa combinação de nac com glicina para
quem se interessar é ter um vídeo Todo
dedicado a essa combinação nac mais
glicina eu vou deixar o link na
descrição outra combinação bem
interessante é o magnésio com glicina
você já com certeza já deve ter ouvido
falar dessa combinação certo o magnésio
glicina também chamado de magnésio
glicinato ou magnésio bisglicinato todos
se referem a um suplemento de magnésio
ligado a aminoácido glicina e todos são
uma forma quelada do magnésio como
exemplo para vocês entenderem cada 100
mg de magnésio elementar para cada 100
mg de magnésio alimentar que você toma
na forma de magnésio
bisglicinato Você também está recebendo
cerca de 620 MG de glicina essa
informação é basiada na composição
química do magnésio bisglicinato que é
composto por magnésio ligado a duas
moléculas de glicina Então essa
combinação atua muito bem na questão do
sono e da ansiedade você já sabe as
inúmeras funções do magnésio certo se
não sabe assiste os meus vídeos a
respeito e o magnésio ajuda a melhorar o
sono também mas quando ele está
combinado com a glicina o potencial É
Ainda Melhor em grande parte isso se
deve a glicina porque ela ajuda a
adormecer mais rápido então ela ajuda a
diminuir a temperatura corporal mantendo
uma temperatura ideal para você pegar no
sono e ela promove esse equilíbrio
térmico mostrando pro seu corpo que é
hora de
descansar mas não é só essa questão a
glicina tem um potencial bem
interessante para aquelas pessoas que
acordam no meio da noite isso porque ela
também atua na qualidade do seu sono
especificamente no sono profundo aquele
sono restaurador que melhora a nossa
saúde física e mental estamos falando do
famoso sono rein esse sono rein é
fundamental pois ajuda você a memorizar
informações consolidando as mesmas que
foram aprendidas durante o dia e também
é importante para a memória há vários
estudos que mostram que a glicina
aumenta significativamente o nosso sono
REM por todos esses motivos a combinação
da glicina com magnésio pode funcionar
bem para muitas pessoas que podem estar
apimentando insônia
depois de ouvir tantos benefícios da
glicina você pode estar pensando em
combiná-la com aqueles nutrientes que Eu
mencionei como a vitamina C o nac ou
magnésio mas como fazer isso geralmente
você já encontra suplementos de glicina
combinados com esses elementos magnésio
por exemplo magnésio bisglicinato já
mencionado e pros outros você
provavelmente precisará de suplementação
separada ou seu médico poderá solicitar
a suplementação das duas substâncias em
conjunto uma única manipulação você pode
obter glicina de um suplemento de
colágeno de boa qualid idade ou como
suplemento separado de glicina pura
disponível em pó ou cápsula dependendo
do fabricante e da forma de manipulação
em termos de dosagem geralmente é bem
seguro tomar de 3 a 5 g de glicina ao
dia e qual que é o melhor horário para
melhorar o sono é melhor tomar glicina
cerca de 30 a 60 minutos antes de dormir
para desempenho físico e recuperação
muscular a glicina também pode ser muito
útil então tomar glicina antes do treino
pode ser uma opção pode melhorar sua
performance pois ela é um precursor da
creatina essencial para a energia
muscular após o treino também pode
ajudar na recuperação muscular porque
vai ajudar o quê você já sabe né
contribui na síntese de proteínas na
reparação de tecidos por causa do
colágeno para suporte cognitivo e
ansiedade você pode tomar agrina pela
manhã Isso é uma boa opção ela ata
melhorando o humor e a função cognitiva
ao longo do dia para tratar a inflamação
crônica em conjunto com o nac você pode
tomar a combinação duas vezes ao dia
para ter os melhores benefícios Como
sempre falo consulte o seu médico ou
médica antes de incluir qualquer
suplementação na sua rotina Ok muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração você é
feira compartilhe os vídeos façil bem a
vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do
alend do TR sem volva